twelve million people live in Kinshasa
capital of the Democratic Republic of
Congo last week the government put the
city under lockdown to cop Carano virus
outbreak bars restaurants and charges
are closed public transport in and out
of the capital is also restricted but
people here say the closure of some food
and vegetable markets has affected the
most we haven't been able to access the
main market in the city for about a week
now we have no way of restocking our
shops I doubt we'll be able to survive
these measures for another week the
goombah district health workers are
cleaning up a government building where
several people including a government
mr. tested positive for the virus
they say the lockdown is necessary to
stop it spreading pull the eyes oh baby
don't we can't lock down all of Kinshasa
for now for obvious reasons but we do
believe that the current lockdown will
help control the pandemic and the city's
main epicenter since like these are
becoming common in Kinshasa the sellers
say these alternative remedies prevent
coronel virus infection and can treat
the virus the drinks are made from
leaves and roots and are becoming
popular with local people while there is
no scientific evidence that these
alternative remedies can work some here
swear by their efficacy the medicine
from this plant is effective against
almost every ailment this is what we
prefer to use instead of going to the
hospital every time we fall sick as long
as we take it every day we should be
free from the corona virus apart from
covered 19 the Democratic Republic of
Congo is also battling a measles
epidemic that has killed more than 5,300
children since early 2019
they are also thought to 1,000 recorded
cases of cholera and a second death
linked to Ebola after two months without
new cases the Public Health System is
already weak here and with all these
diseases many are asking whether it can
cope
mohammed abu al jazeera